يسرني ويسعدني ان ارحب باعضاء من كره
البنات السعوديه من جده يسعد هالصباح يسعد
صباحكم جميعا بالاول
بناته شباب
يسعد صباحكم
[موسيقى]
انا كثير سعيده بوجودكم معنا اليوم على
برنامج صباح العربيه على شاشه العربيه
وبتمنى تكونوا عم تسمعوني معنا امل وعبد
الله العزيز اللي رح نتواصل معكم في
الاسئله نسمع امل اكيد راح ابلش معك لانه
كورال بنات السعوديه وليدي دايما بس كمان
بدي اعرف شغله اذا اسمه كورال بنات
السعوديه ليه في شباب معكم ارجو التوضيح
اولا
صباح الخير اول حاجه احنا سعيدين انه نحن
نكون معكم اليوم
احنا اسعد بالنسبه لكره البنات السعوديه
احنا كجروب بدينا في 2019
كمجموعه بنات
بالنسبه
للشباب للشباب
عم نسمعك امل بالنسبه للكورال احنا بدينا
لانه نقعد بسمع صدى في اذني
اوكي احنا بدينا في 2019 ككل للبنات
مجموعه في وشاركنا في اول حفله كانت مع
الفنان راشد الماجد تواصل معنا الاخ حسن
طالب وكانت هذه اول مشاركه بنات سعوديات
في حفل في مدينه جده وبعدها تواصلوا معانا
شركه روتانا وكنا مشاركين معاهم في موسم
الرياض مع الاخ محمد الهاجري واكيد شركه
روتانا وسالم الهندي بعدها بعد فتره صار
في عندنا جروب بنات وبعد الموسم الرياض
اشتركوا معانا الشباب فسرنا مجموعه بنات
وشباب عم نشارك في اغلب
الاحتفالات والموسم الرياض والموسم جده
وكل الاحتفالات الفنيه اللي في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه واكيد انتو حضيتم بدعم
كبار الفنانين شاركتهم معهم ايضا في اهم
حفلاتهم في مواسم السعوديه على كل حال
احنا كمان كثير متحمسين انه نسمع منكم
اغنيه ونشوف هذا التناغم
في اعضاء الكورال تفضلوا
شو حابين تسمعونا اليوم
اسمعك ميدلي يلا احلى واحلى
[موسيقى]
انت ما تنسانا اكثر قلبي مو من قلبك
الصغار مثلي ما تشعرتك
فيني منك فيك مني
غصب عنك غصب عني قلت جينا واللي جاك قسمه
مقدار
السيف ولا طاني الكلام
من حبيبي اللي وصلت حضني
من حبيبي اللي وسط حضني
يكفي طعونا سامح الله طاعونا
ماني تحت انا على راس قمه
ما ابغى عيونك جعلت تسلم عيونك عندي كثير
اشياء غيره مهمه
[موسيقى]
الله يسلم هالصوت وانتم انسان اكثر يعني
قلبي معكم مو قلبه اصغر يعني فعلا فعلا
اتحفتونا بهذه الاغنيه ونحن كمان متشوقين
نسمع المزيد بس خليني انا اسمع الشباب
نروح شوي لعبد العزيز عبد العزيز اليوم
لما احنا بنحكي عن كورال يعني الواحد مرات
لحاله بكون بده يغني ويحاول انه يزبط على
الاغنيه صح وانه وكل هاي الامور الموسيقيه
الفنيه طب انتم مجموعه مع بعض كيف بتقدروا
تحافظوا على هذا التوازن وكلكم تكونوا
بنفس الاتجاه
طبعا احنا اولا تاسيس الجروب كان مبني اول
شيء عندنا اداره اعمال
ومن اسس الجروب انه يتكون الجميع يكون
اصواتها حلوه اصوات متناسقه فاهمه موسيقيا
متناغم في الاداء
وعنده كاريزمه الحضور هذه عندنا اساسيات
مهمه جدا يعني حتى في تاسيس الكورال كان
هذه من اهم الاساسيات يعني وهذا اللي
ميزنا للامانه يعني في موضوع الكره يعني
ومش معقول قديش فعلا يعني الكل كان مندمج
ومبسوط وهو عم يسمعكم لما باغنيه انسان
اكثر عن المجيد عبد الله كمان حابين نسمع
منكم كمان وكمان احنا ما شاء الله ترى
الستاف كامل يعني فنانين
وتفضلوا كمان تحبونا يا ريت
[موسيقى]
من قبل اعرفك كاني خلاك
اوفاهم غدرني فوق غدران عرفني الالم عرفني
الاحزان
عشت سنين ظلمه ما وصلها
[موسيقى]
خاطري مكسور اتحمل خطاهم كاني فين
ولما دار الزمان ادور
يرميني عجاجل
الطفل
اواه لو تدري عن بعض
الحنين
والشوق له منا تجبر
لربما لو
هزوق بتيجي
وتعاندي الظروف وقتك يا ترى
يعني انا تمنيت لو انتم موجودين هلا معانا
هون في الاستوديو وجنبنا يعني ما بينشبع
منكم وما بينشبع انه نسمعكم فعلا امل بس
كمان انا بدي اسالك هل لازم انه يكون كل
الاصوات جميله ولا بالكره المرات بتضيع
لا بالعكس هذا شرط مهم انه يكون في الجروب
عندنا يكون الاصوات جميله ومتناسقه يعني
ضروري يعني سواء بنات او شباب لانه احنا
اهم حاجه عندنا انه المعايير الفنيه اللي
احنا حطيناها هي معايير عاليه الصراحه نحب
نحلم نشارك مع اي فنان نكون متواجدين معه
يكون الكورال جميل حتى الفنان ما بيسمعنا
بيكون هو حينطرب وهو حينبسط انه احنا
قاعدين بنقدم من قلبنا وبنؤدي بفن وبتمكن
وطبعا سؤال سريع في عندكم اعمال جديده
الناس بانتظارها عبد الرحمن
عبد الرحمن
معلش السؤال اهم اعمالكم الجديده
المستقبليه
ان شاء الله حيكون عندنا اكثر من عمل وفي
عندنا ان شاء الله الحفل القادمه مع
الفنان الكبير عبد المجيد عبد الله
نتشرف فيها باذن الله
واحنا كتير اسعدتونا واطربتونا وان شاء
الله بنشوفكم كمان مباشره وجها لوجه
وبنسمع كمان
الماده والاغاني الجميله من على مسارح في
السعوديه شكرا جزيلا لكم من جدة كره
البنات السعوديه